Trascrizione: Emma Linford
Revisore: Alessandra Tadiotto
(Musica)
(Applausi)
Grazie, grazie di cuore
per questa calorosissima accoglienza.
Buon pomeriggio a tutti.
Io sono qui, quest'oggi,
per parlarvi di musica improvvisata.
Ovvero, musica la cui corretta definizione
si traduce in composizione estemporanea.
Viene da sé un interrogativo:
"Ma improvvisare musica
significa suonare
quello che mi viene in mente
in un determinato momento,
suonare senza alcune regole,
alcune norme da seguire,
e quindi lasciarsi andare completamente
a impulsi e istinti
di tipo creativo e artistico?"
Sì, in realtà è anche questo:
tuttavia, l'improvvisazione
si avvale di tantissime regole.
Ci sono proprio delle norme da seguire.
E che poi, a seconda
del periodo storico che si considera,
dello stile e del gusto della dissonanza
si possono trasgredire o meno.
L'importante, secondo me,
per trasgredire una regola
è sempre quella di conoscerla
adeguatamente, prima.
Io ho conosciuto la musica
all'età di sette anni,
quando mi venne diagnosticata
una forte asma respiratoria.
Sì, fa ridere ma in effetti è così.
Oltre alle punture di cortisone
che mi spaventavano da morire
mi venne anche consigliato
un rimedio "omeopatico",
ovvero quello di suonare
uno strumento a fiato.
E io sono qui, quest'oggi,
perché seguii quel consiglio.
Venni subito affascinato -
Studiai in conservatorio,
quindi avendo una formazione classica:
la classica mi ha sempre
appassionato tantissimo.
Però la mia vita cambiò
quando, per la prima volta,
mi trovai ad improvvisare
un breve periodo musicale.
L'enorme potere, se vogliamo,
che conferisce questo strumento
penso che sia davvero inappagabile,
qualcosa di impossibile da descrivere.
Il fatto che un musicista
possa svincolarsi da un pezzo di carta
e suonare secondo le sue regole,
secondo i suoi istinti.
Tengo spesso masterclass didattiche
in Italia e in Europa
e mi accorgo che musicisti
che hanno magari avuto
la mia stessa esperienza
nel campo classico
sono assolutamente disorientati,
Non sanno cosa inventarsi.
Il fatto è che appunto, come dicevo prima,
non ci si improvvisa improvvisatori.
Bisogna conoscere determinate regole.
Ovviamente in questi pochi minuti
non mi è possibile illustrarvele tutte
per filo e per segno.
Tuttavia, voi pensate a un paragone
che secondo me è piuttosto sensato:
paragonarlo a un linguaggio verbale.
Per esempio, molti di noi
hanno studiato una lingua straniera,
vuoi alle elementari o alle medie.
Spesso ci viene un po' ridotta
a una serie di regole grammaticali
che noi in modo un po' maccheronico,
spesso, cerchiamo di mettere insieme.
Tuttavia, lo stesso è nella musica.
Non si può ridurre a una semplice
operazione artificiosa,
bensì bisogna arrivare a quel grado
di coscienza di un determinato linguaggio
che ci consente di parlare fluentemente.
Tutti noi improvvisiamo, quando parliamo.
Io ho in mente un concetto
che voglio comunicare
ed estemporaneamente
trovo le parole per farlo.
Succede un po' questo.
La cosa veramente importante
è conoscere a fondo il linguaggio
con il quale ci si va a misurare.
Tutti pensano che l'improvvisazione
esista solo nel jazz: in realtà, no.
Il jazz non ha scoperto l'acqua calda
ma ha semplicemente
rielaborato, inizialmente,
la canzone di Broadway,
la canzone tradizionale americana,
ha rielaborato un concetto
che viene dalla musica classica.
Tantissimi autori della musica classica
erano degli eccellenti improvvisatori.
Citiamo soprattutto Mozart e Bach.
Specialmente Bach:
Io sono un grandissimo
ammiratore del suo operato
e studio la musica che lui scrisse
quasi tutti i giorni.
Volevo infatti, a questo proposito,
farvi sentire un piccolo esperimento.
Cioè, io, grande appassionato
di musica barocca e classica
posso inventare qualcosa
anche su un brano che, stilisticamente,
esula totalmente dalla musica jazz.
Questo soltanto per darvi
un esempio pratico
di come, in realtà, l'improvvisazione
è più una questione
di gestione degli spazi
e di appropriamento del linguaggio.
Noi dobbiamo proprio impadronirci
del linguaggio che vogliamo andare
a rendere estemporaneo.
(Musica)
(Applausi)
In questo momento, per esempio,
io ho estrapolato un frammento
delle Suite per violoncello di Bach
ma senza assolutamente sapere
cosa andavo a suonarci intorno.
Per questo il concetto
di "improvvisazione"
si rifà un po' al concetto
di "Variazione sul tema".
Quindi c'è sempre un materiale tematico
che viene rielaborato.
Io ho voluto azzardare,
nella mia carriera artistica,
un po' di più
e ho appena registrato un nuovo album
che si intitola "Beyond",
nel quale ho fatto i conti, addirittura,
con autrici del calibro
di Lady Gaga, Shakira e Jennifer Lopez.
La cosa, sì, ha destato molto stupore,
tuttavia sono riuscito a inserire
questa idea di estemporaneità.
È un disco a me molto caro
perché ha due valenze:
quella artistica, perché "Beyond"
significa "Al di là di"
e quindi ho voluto un po' abbattere
le barriere tra i generi,
mettendo in atto il concetto
che mi trovo a comunicarvi quest'oggi;
e poi una valenza umana,
perché è legato a una persona
che voglio ricordare
perché è la persona alla quale devo tutto,
ed è mia madre, che purtroppo
un anno fa è scomparsa.
E anche questo, però, è in tema
con l'argomento di oggi
perché io mi feci molta forza
e durante la messa
celebrativa di mia madre
mi trovai a improvvisare
qualcosa in chiesa
che non conoscevo
assolutamente, per nulla.
Quindi un'applicazione
che va ancora più al di là
del concetto di "tema".
Improvvisare proprio un tema, una melodia.
Quello che poi, a sua volta,
dovrebbe dettare un'improvvisazione
è già improvvisazione.
Bene, io questo tema poi lo estrapolai,
perché fu talmente vivido il ricordo in me
che fui in grado, appena arrivato
a casa, di scrivermela
e appunto feci un brano
che si intitola "Beyond"
che ha dato il nome all'album.
Tutto qua, ecco.
Sappiate che comunque,
anche senza materiale precostituito,
anche senza barriere fra i generi
si può comunque improvvisare.
E consiglio ad ognuno di voi, davvero,
di non credere che sia mai troppo tardi
per entrare nel mondo della musica.
Anche in modo non professionale,
perché comunque la musica
è fonte di grande arricchimento
per la mente di ognuno di noi.
E vi voglio salutare con pochi secondi
estrapolati proprio
da questo brano, "Beyond".
Grazie ancora per l'attenzione.
(Applausi)
(Musica)
Grazie.
(Applausi)